[Musik]
im osten deutschlands gab der sommer
2009 10 heute seine abschiedsvorstellung
ein sonniger wahlsonntag in brandenburg
potsdam zieht touristen und einheimische
an rund um den landtag im stadtschloss
in sachsen in der hauptstadt dresden
konnten ein paar gewitter den blick auf
die berühmte stadtkulisse nicht trüben
der sächsische landtag ist heute
anziehungspunkt für politiker bürger und
journalisten und auch wir berichten von
hier aus aus unserem zdf wahlstudio über
die ergebnisse dieses abends und von
hier herzlich willkommen hier also aus
dresden wir nehmen sachsen aber genauso
auch brandenburg von hier aus in den
blick heute abend zwei landtagswahlen
die vielleicht seit 1990 nicht mehr so
spannend waren wie heute wenn es geht um
zwei stamm länder in einem sachsen
regiert die cdu im anderen brandenburg
die spd seit fast 30 jahren und jetzt
ist die große frage ob das so bleibt
matthias ja fast nichts wird so bleiben
wie es war so viel kann man jetzt schon
sagen denn die politische landschaft die
wird doch ziemlich umgepflügt in ganz
deutschland insgesamt aber vor allem im
osten denn da sammelt die afg so
ziemlich alles ein was es an protest an
unzufriedenheit und an frust gibt und
sie wird damit zweitstärkste kraft
mindestens und weil niemand mit der afg
regieren will bleibt sie so eine art
anti block in den parlamenten und das
macht es schwieriger mehrheiten zu
finden
die gerupften volksparteien cdu und spd
die werden sich deshalb wohl auf
dreierbündnisse einstellen müssen so ist
es aber erst mal kommen die ergebnisse
wie immer pünktlich um 18 uhr die
prognose der forschungsgruppe wahlen für
sachsen und für brandenburg und wir
können die zeit bis dahin gut nutzen und
die ausgangslage in beiden ländern ein
bisschen sortieren
beginnen wir in brandenburg seit 1990
lag die spd bei landtagswahlen immer
vorn
diese spitzenposition ist aber womöglich
kein automatismus mehr
matthias kubitz berichtet
wer kämpft sich als erster ins ziel spd
und fdp liegen kopf an kopf wird dem
schwächelnden dauersieger in rot die
puste ausgehen gegen die blaue
konkurrenz brandenburg 30 jahre nach der
wende zwischen preußen glanz und die
industrialisierte provinz hier wohlstand
dort niedergang stimmungen zwischen
früher war es besser und lust auf neues
die themen der brandenburger ganz
verschieden
er kann sich das schicke potsdam leisten
warum gibt es kaum netz sind die
prignitz oder in der uckermark und wie
soll es in der lausitz ohne kohle laufen
ungleiche lebensgefühle in einem land
also kohle
die hätte wohl mehr gewusst ich sehe
keinen anderen arbeitgeber und ich sehe
das auch sehr hochgespielt also klima
ich kann es eigentlich nicht mehr hören
wurde übertrieben die schulen sind ohne
lehrer und ausgebildete lehrer wer hier
kein auto hat auf dem dorf an der iss
landesvater dietmar beugt gemeint den
schuss gehört zu haben
dr sachlich wie er einst betitelt wurde
setzt auf bürgernähe der beinahe zwei
meter mann hilft seine spd in
brandenburg zwar deutlich über
bundesschnitt trotzdem drohen drastische
verluste
werde mit vollem einsatz meinetwegen 16
18 20 stunden am tag dafür arbeiten dass
hier nicht die rechtspopulisten stärkste
kraft werden
die afg punktet als ost verstehe midwest
in porz andreas kalbitz der
spitzenkandidat metalls rechtsextremer
bieter setzt auf fundamental opposition
entscheidend ist jetzt dass wir
möglichst viele prozente bekommen ich
denke dass der demokratische weg in die
verantwortung natürlich über die
opposition läuft die linke deutlich
zweistellig aber sicher mit verlusten
will weiter mitregieren
für diejenigen die sich die abgehängt
sind die nicht so leistungsfähig sind
die benachteiligt sind auch die cdu
schippert wohl schwächer über die
zielgerade als beim letzten mal
spitzenkandidat ingo senftleben hofft
trotzdem ministerpräsident zu werden mit
der afg würde er keinesfalls koalieren
mit der linken vielleicht schon die wahl
wird eng ausgehen deswegen sollte man
sich vorher nicht zu sehr festlegen und
ehrlich selbst überrascht zu werden
wir wollen in bayreuth zum ersten mal
den politikwechsel schaffen nach 30
jahren spd es gibt viel zu tun die
grünen wohl deutlich erfolgreicher als
vor fünf jahren profitieren vom
bundestrend
die menschen spüren der klimawandel
betrifft sie jetzt auch und er ist auch
hier in brandenburg angekommen knapp in
den landtag könnten ist diesmal die
liberalen schaffen und vielleicht wieder
die freien wähler bis zum ziel kämpft
jeder für sich
rot schwarz oder grün finden danach
sicher partner ein blauer sieg dagegen
der ein einsamer ohne option auf macht
ja und dann der spitze läuft es auf
einen zweikampf zwischen spd und afg
hinaus und an der stelle wird immer der
amtsbonus besonders wichtig wie stark
ist denn der ausgeprägt beim
ministerpräsidenten heute auf jeden fall
bettina finden die brandenburger das
dietmar woidke seine sache gut macht und
das sehen wir hier gleich an den ersten
beiden grafiken 47 prozent der befragten
den brandenburg wollen wollte als
ministerpräsidenten behalten 23 prozent
wünschen sich von der cdu ingo
senftleben und noch größer ist der
vorsprung für feuz im vergleich zum afc
spitzenkandidaten andreas kalb
52 prozent zu 12 prozent es gibt also
einen amtsbonus wenn auch nicht ganz so
ausgeprägt wie vor fünf jahren
aber welche themen sind eigentlich
wichtig im land und das ist ganz
interessant sehen wir in der nächsten
grafik da ist ganz oben das thema
infrastruktur und das meint alles vom
nahverkehr über schnelles internet bis
zur ärztlichen versorgung mit einigem
abstand dann klassische themen bildung
klima arbeitslosigkeit und interessant
auch nur noch zwölf prozent nennen das
thema flüchtlinge zehn jahren rot-rot
regiert brandenburg die wir sind
ziemlich sicher dass es dafür nicht mehr
reichen wird was stellen sie sich denn
die menschen im land vor na ja für ein
zweierbündnis wird es grundsätzlich
nicht reichen in brandenburg wir sehen
in den umfragen ja auch eher fünf
mittelstarke parteien da sind viele
bündnisse rechnerisch möglich wir
schauen mal auf 1 was auch gegen konz
könnte nämlich rot rot grün und das
fänden hier in brandenburg 41 prozent
gut 43 prozent schlecht wenn wir auf die
andere seite der grafik gucken die
anhänger von linken und grünen sind
relativ angetan
die anhänger der spd ein bisschen
zögerlich st matthias da fragen wir noch
mal nach bei unserer studioleiterin in
brandenburg bettina warten die den
wahlkampf intensiv beobachtet hat
bettina das rennen um die spitze ist eng
und die spd drohte zu verlieren wie
haben sie denn die stimmung im wahlkampf
im land wahrgenommen
ja auf jeden fall die ganze zeit
spannend es ging immer auf und ab wer
liegt vorne
wer liegt anstelle 2 und wer hier bei
uns hinter den im landtag als stärkste
kraft einziehen will das werden wir
hinterher sehen
ich bin auf jeden fall durchs land
gereist mit meinen kollegen und die
haben das land ganz unterschiedlich
wahrgenommen
sind sie in der uckermark dann ist es
vor allen dingen die mobilität dass die
menschen nicht mehr von a nach b kommen
da kann man nur sagen wenn der schulbus
der einst das einzige verkehrsmittel ist
und das pferd von montags bis freitags
ja was machen die menschen am wochenende
sind sie in der lausitz an reagieren die
menschen ängstlichen skeptisch ängstlich
dass sie vielleicht ihre arbeitsplätze
in der braunkohle verlieren aber auch
skeptisch ob die versprochenen millionen
jemals ankommen und der speckgürtel rund
um potsdam haben sie ganz andere
probleme da fahren nicht genügend züge
nach berlin wo die viele ihrer arbeit
haben
der wird das wohnen immer teurer das
heißt es gibt viele unterschiedliche
probleme im land und nicht alle sehen
das es war wirklich schnelle lösungen
gibt in ihrem netz wirklichkeit sieht es
so aus dass sie sich abgehängt fühlen
funkloch in ganz brandenburg aber wir
werden sehen die spitzenkandidaten
kommen auf jeden fall auch zu uns in die
19 uhr runde und zwar hier in unserer
gläsernes zdf-studio dass wir direkt am
landtag aufgebaut haben und dann werden
wir alle fragen stellen können
ja danke schön bettina sie werden genau
dafür uns heute die stellung halten in
potsdam genauso wie unsere reporter die
die stimmungslage bei den einzelnen
parteien in brandenburg beobachten und
wir beginnen mal bei ralf schipanski der
die regierungspartei spd heute abend
beobachtet reif ja unsicherheit
zuversicht was überwiegt da auf der
wahlparty der sozialdemokraten
ich sag mal so der blick von hier oben
auf dem nikolaikirchhof sich die
aussichten für die spd sind es nicht
matthias platzeck der langjährige
ministerpräsident hier in brandenburg
von der spd hat es so ausgedrückt die
grundstimmung im land sei um gut das hat
verschiedene gründe wir haben schon ein
paar gehört vor allem aber ist es
eigentlich unverständlich denn die
wirtschaftlichen zahlen sind gut
brandenburg boomt die spd aber kann vor
allem im ländlichen bereich nicht so
recht davon profitieren und so ist man
hier auf der wahlparty durchaus demütig
geworden
fast 30 jahre lang waren stärkste kraft
fast 30 jahre lang ist man an der
regierung stellte ministerpräsidenten
heute aber heißt das minimalziel
wenigstens vor der afd
gelingt dies nicht erscheint alles
möglich aus sicht der spd also ist
wirklich für spannung gesorgt
vielen dank ralf und wir schauen weiter
zum regierungspartner der spd den linken
seit zehn jahren besteht die rot rote
koalition
katrin lindner weiter mitregieren oder
nicht das ist ja die frage
ja das ist die frage
wir sind hier im fußballstadion von
babelsberg 03 linker fußballverein und
linke wahlparty das passt schon mal die
spitzenkandidatin der linken kathrin
dannenberg sagt sie ist sportlerin und
will gewinnen
am liebsten 20 prozent plus x.de
mitrechnet hier niemand die stimmung ist
abwartend
seit zehn jahren regieren die
sozialdemokraten gemeinsam mit den
linken
dass das so weitergeht befürchten sie
wird diesmal nicht funktionieren sie
hoffen auf rot-rot-grün auf grün setzt
hier auch schon das fußballstadion mit
erneuerbaren energien und hafermehl
statt kuhmilch vielleicht ein zeichen
für die linke und damit zurück ins
wahlstudio dankeschön katrin lindner
martin cordes bei der afg heute abend
die ja nach der europawahl ende mai nun
erneut stärkste kraft in brandenburg
werden will
martin aber auch an zwei wäre ja ein
wirklich großer erfolg für die afd
ich habe timo das wäre es sicherlich
aber die afg setzt auf sieg und nicht
auf platz 20 prozent muss das ist auch
hier das erklärte wahlziel die partei
ist für die wahlparty aus der
landeshauptstadt potsdam wo demos und
proteste drohten ausgewichen ins
benachbarte werder
hier trifft man sich im prachtvollen
ballsaal des historischen garten lokals
bismarckhöhe also kfd trumpft groß aus
und tut das zumindest schon mal mit
dieser tollen location hier
spannend wird sein zu sehen ob der
spitzenkandidat der fdp andreas kalbitz
auf den letzten metern noch zum problem
wird denn in dieser woche gab es wieder
neue enthüllungen über einen
rechtsextremistischen hintergrund eine
rechtsextremistische vergangenheit von
andreas kaatz
ob da dann doch noch jahren oder andere
abgeschreckt wird sie werden sie nur
viertelstunde wissen zurück ins studio
dankeschön warten ja den wahlabend wird
wie immer professor karl rudolf korte
mit uns beobachten schönen guten abend
neu dabei sind es auch heute wir sehen
zwei länder in denen die bisher
regierenden parteien doch erheblich
unter druck stehen
bleiben wir zunächst mal in brandenburg
war steht dafür die spd die ja auch im
bund unter druck steht was steht dort
auf dem spiel sehr viel für die spd denn
das ist eine wie eine zäsur heute abend
so ist zu erwarten
die dominanz parteien verlieren an kraft
regionale stellung die sie über
jahrzehnte hatten sind weg und das wird
die theorie geradezu die todessehnsucht
der spd im bund am ende auch aus der
coco rauszugehen noch einmal beflügeln
auch dann wenn die spd in brandenburg
wenn dietmar woidke durchaus stärkste
kraft würde dass er mit mehreren
partnern das schafft also nicht mehr
großpartei plus kleinpartei gleich
mehrheit könnte ja von den zahlen her
klappen dass sie mit ist er mit mehreren
an der macht bleibt dann ist die chance
die todessehnsucht auszuleben eher
gering
nun stellt sich die politische
landschaft neu auf hat man den eindruck
in brandenburg genauso wie in sachsen
ist die afg stark dafür war sie ja im
übrigen auch schon bei der bundestagwahl
2017 auch bei der europawahl haben wir
gesehen letztes letzten mai wir sehen
hier schon das konnte man auch im
wahlkampf beobachten dass da jetzt eine
starke polarisierung da ist ja dass
sollen wie ein block gegen die afd
die eine alltags partei hier geworden
ist es um 20 und 25 prozent bei allen
wahlen geholt hat aber niemand hat
diesmal versucht die auf die rechts zu
überholen
seit der bayern wahl wird dieses
experiment nicht mehr gefahren
es führt zu einer enormen politisierung
enorme mobilisierung im alltag was die
hoch zeit für wahlkämpfe ja nicht
minimiert sondern eher positiv für die
demokratie ist und dann ist die
ausstellung er afd auf der einen alle
anderen auf der anderen seite genau das
ist die polarisierung hier zu beobachten
ist aber in anderen landtagen und
anderen parteien anderen wahlkämpfen
auch so und wir sehen dass das in der
regel dann auch zu höheren
wahlbeteiligung natürlich geführt diese
ausgangslagen herzlichen dank für den
moment wir sprechen später weiter und
schauen dann jetzt mal genauer auf
sachsen hier ist es ministerpräsident
michael kretschmer der antworten auf die
stärke der afg finden muss zuletzt sah
es in den umfragen so aus dass er heute
den spitzenplatz für die
cdu behaupten kann aber die
regierungsbildung dürfte schwieriger
werden noch einmal matthias kubitz in
ihrem wunsch nach recht und freiheit
waren sich die sachsen ein ich genau vor
30 jahren heute das land extrem
gespalten vor allem beim thema
flüchtlinge und migration alles guckt
auf sachsen in diesen hitzigen zeiten
wer heißt hier wen willkommen und wer
nicht und wer ist im freistaat wovon
abgehängt das stolze sachsen war schon
vieles von königlich bis sozialistisch
von weltniveau bis unterirdisch heute
muss sachsen als symbol herhalten weil
der riss der durch deutschland geht hier
besonders sichtbar ist wer sich
integrieren will
zu arcandor bleiben aber ja nicht dass
wir willens ist da gibt es viele viele
beispiele die müssen wir gehen also das
ist ein thema von vorgestern
das führt hoch gebaut von af derweil
dass das nicht die wer fängt ich glaube
es ist kein grund zum jammern denke ich
uns geht's gut sind sehr viele
enttäuscht von der regierung muss ich
sage ich auch ministerpräsident michael
kretschmer hat sich alles angehört
wollte rastlos deutschland zu seinen
sachsen die strategie der klaren kanten
einerseits scharf gegen die afd
aber auch deutlich gegen die bundes cdu
scheint aufzugehen die union wohl form
und jetzt geht es darum bei dieser
landtagswahl für diesen ansatz auch eine
mehrheit zu bekommen wenn wir in zukunft
auch in berlin eine starke stimme haben
wollen brauchen wir hier eine starke
stabile regierung
der sieg der afg schien manchen schon
sicher doch spitzenkandidat jörg urban
kann als personen kaum punkten
oft gibt er sich bürgerlich kann aber
auch radikal und hetzerisch die die zu
hunderttausenden in unser land
einwandern sind wenn überhaupt
fachkräfte für sozialbetrug düstere
aussichten für die spd wohl unter zehn
prozent
für wirtschaftsminister du nicht zahlt
sich die regierungsarbeit nicht aus wir
haben das ruder herumgerissen der staats
abbau in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode
den haben wir beendet wir haben wieder
stellen aufgebaut bei polizei bei den
lehrerinnen und lehrer im öffentlichen
dienst auch die linke deutlich gestutzt
ihre einstige wählerschaft nicht mehr
treu und zuverlässig größte sorge die
die leute haben ist dass die schere
zwischen arm und reich immer weiter
auseinander wird
die grünen dagegen können wahrscheinlich
dazu gewinnen
sie profitieren von der
gesellschaftlichen polarisierung am
meisten
wir wollen aber ganz klar mit zuversicht
und weltoffenheit und wirklich mit einer
ganz klaren haltung diesem wahlkampf
entscheiden holger zastrow fdp könnte es
nach fünf jahren pause wieder in den
landtag schaffen
frauke petry und ihre blauen dagegen
müssen wahrscheinlich aus im gespaltenen
sachsen sind die argumente und parolen
ausreichend ausgetauscht
jetzt ist zeit für zahlen
so ist es genau genommen sind es noch
achteinhalb minuten bis zur prognose wir
haben gesehen ministerpräsident
kretschmann ist unermüdlich durchs land
verreist jetzt ist die frage ob das
gereicht hat matthias vor wie sind seine
persönlichen werte für seine werte
bettina die sind tatsächlich gut an
herausforderer auf augenhöhe denn gibt
es nicht das mag an der schwäche anderer
kandidaten liegen aber es liegt sicher
auch an der stärke des
ministerpräsidenten
denn dass michael kretschmer seine
arbeit gut macht das sagen 78 prozent
der befragten das ist ein
außergewöhnlich hoher zustimmungswert
und sogar jeder zweite anhänger der afd
findet dass kretschmer seine arbeit gut
macht die regierungsbildung wird wohl
trotzdem kein selbstläufer denn
kretschmann hat eine koalition mit der
fdp ausgeschlossen und um mit der spd
weiterregieren zu können müsste er die
grünen mit ins boot machen wir sehen wie
das hier ankäme 42 prozent finden das
gut 42 prozent schlecht 50 fifty also
genau und bei den anhängern der drei
beteiligten parteien da gibt es
erwartbarer weise klare zustimmung zu
seinem bündnis ja dass dann auch die
große frage ob das wirklich geschmiedet
werden kann das können wir gleich
unseren zdf studioleiter wir in sachsen
fragen michael bewerunge ein kenia
bündnis nennt man das ja wegen der
farben auf der landesflagge schwarz-rot
mit grün könnte das in sachsen
geschmiedet werden könnte das
funktionieren
ich denke schon also von spd und grüne
seite mit sicherheit es ist für beide
parteien nicht die wunschkoalition aber
eindeutig auch im vorfeld ausgedrückte
gewünschte koalition die cdu zieht sich
noch etwas
ministerpräsident kretschmann wollte
sich vorher nicht festlegen lassen
aber es gab ja schon mal 2014 fast eine
schwarz-grüne koalition also untrennbar
auseinander ist man da nicht und für
kretschmann wird es darauf ankommen er
ist ja seit seiner wahl hier 2017 schon
durch das land getingelt quasi im
dauerwahlkampf modus er muss seine union
so stark wie möglich machen um überhaupt
eine regierung hier führen zu können
ein zusammengehen mit der afg hat er
ausgeschlossen in einer koalition aber
auch in einer minderheitsregierung also
etwa eine tolerierung jetzt hat ja die
aufstellung der listenplätze der afg
hier schon für einigen wirbel gesorgt da
gab es schon ein urteil des
landesverfassungsgericht die liste wurde
begrenzt das könnte ja noch eine rolle
spielen auch im nachgang der wahl in der
tat die geschichte ist noch nicht zu
ende das landesverfassungsgericht hat
die wahlliste der afg auf 30 plätze
begrenzt sind aber die direktmandate
offen dh die könnten einige mehr sein
die frage ist wie viele von der
landeswahl ist da stehen auch viele
direktkandidaten drauf können da noch
ergänzt werden und so wie es
möglicherweise aussieht fehlen dann ein
ende plätze die der afg zuständen könnte
mit ihrem zweitstimmenergebnis und die
afg hat schon angekündigt dass sie so
oder so auf jeden fall den
wahlprüfungsausschuss das ist dann die
juristische weg im nachgang im neuen
parlament anrufen wird und diese wahl
anfechten werde das hatten wir im
übrigen beim letzten mal auch schon hat
dann zwei jahre gedauert also nur das
man das schon mal gehört hat für den
heutigen abend ist das von relevanz
vielen dank michael bunk für den moment
ja dann hören wir jetzt mal genauer hier
nach der stimmung in sachsen
wie stehen die einzelnen parteien so da
wie bereiten sie sich vor
fehring ist bei der wahlparty der grünen
bisher schwach in sachsen und jetzt der
schon wir haben es gehört im gespräch
als regierungspartner ja da dürfte dann
die stimmung ganz gut sein richtig ist
absolut bettina die grünen sind hier in
die dresdner neustadt gekommen
in den clubs station und sie sind
gekommen um zu feiern hier läuft auch
schon ordentlich musik und ich habe eben
schon mit der spitzenkandidatin katja
meier sprechen können sie sagt sie hofft
auf ein gutes zweistelliges ergebnis sie
selbst hat mal den bass in einer
punkband gespielt ja und auch die grünen
wollen hier in sachsen künftig den takt
mit anbieten ob ein mögliches
zusammenspiel mit der cdu allerdings so
harmonisch klingen würde ist eher
fraglich aber das ist jetzt noch
zukunftsmusik die grünen sind hier auf
jeden fall absolut guter dinge und jetzt
schon in feierlaune
mal sehen ob es auch gleich sein wird
und damit zurück zu dir bettina
ja danke schön in fehring allerdings
waren grünen häufig auch schon stärker
in umfragen als dann nachher in
ergebnissen wir werden das sehen von den
grünen zur fdp die um zweitstimmen wird
um wieder in den landtag überhaupt
einzuziehen länder gestern bei den
liberalen was das ist schon wirklich
eine wackelpartie für die fdp richtig
hoffen und zittern müssen die liberalen
hier in sachsen
ob es dieses mal klappt mit dem einzug
in den sächsischen landtag oder eben
nicht bei der letzten landtagswahl 2014
da flog die fdp heraus landete bei
gerade mal 3,8 prozent und die letzten
umfragen lagen sie bei fünf prozent also
knapp drin im landtag hier in dresden da
sind die liberalen sehr zuversichtlich
glauben fest an ein comeback und an
bessere zahlen wenn auch mit weichen
knien und ob sie sich hier ganz locker
machen können oder nicht das sehen wir
dann vielleicht schon in einigen minuten
danke schön wenn pakistan weiter zu afd
die thomas bärsch im wahlkampf in
sachsen beobachtet hat und das auch
heute abend tun wird thomas stärkste
kraft in sachsen bei der bundestagswahl
2010 bund bei der europawahl jetzt
letzten mai rechnet die afg denn damit
dass sich dieser lauf heute fortsetzt
also wir haben ja viele getroffen die
rechnen und damit die messen den erfolg
heute daran ob sie hier stärkste kraft
werden
die der optimismus speist sich aus den
umfragen
das war ja auch die zeit im sommer als
der landesvorsitzende sagte eine
koalition mit der cdu kommt nur in frage
wenn die cdu sich der afg unterordne
solche stimmen haben wir heute hier
nicht gehört es gibt auch moderate
stimmen die sagen 25x wer auch in
ordnung und verweisen darauf dass das ja
auch eine vereinfachung des ergebnisses
von der letzten landtagswahl 2014 wäre
so weit von hier dankeschön thomas für
die ersten eindrücke und wir gehen dann
noch weiter zu wolf schmiese der bei der
cdu sachsen de ist wulff musste sind ja
für die cdu vorhergesagt und trotzdem
könnte michael kretschmer ja tatsächlich
heute abend als gewinner vom platz gehen
wie sind denn die erwartungen
genauso sind die verwaltungen bettina du
siehst hinter mir da ist uhr biedenkopf
der langjährige große ministerpräsident
der als könig wird gefeiert wird also
man hat sich fest vorgenommen man will
alles feiern was über 30 prozent ist und
damit rechnet hier die cdu obwohl sie in
den letzten wochen doch etwas an
selbstbewusstsein verloren hatte
hauptsache also über 30 prozent und der
abstand zur afg soll gegeben sein dass
man stärkste partei bleibt insofern ja
kretschmann könnte hier als sieger
gefeiert werden
auch wenn er das schlechteste
landtagswahlergebnis der cdu ein pferd
was die cdu in sachsen je erlebt hat das
werden wir sehen in knapp zwei minuten
das prognose ergebnis der
forschungsgruppe wahlen
und dann können wir uns noch mal
gemeinsam ein wenig auf sachsen
konzentrieren professor karl rudolf
korte ist bei mir kretschmann hat in der
schlussphase dieses wahlkampf sicher vor
allem klar abgegrenzt zu afd nicht mit
zustimmung aller ortsverbände in seiner
landespartei aber es war ja auch die
einzige chance richtig ja die
sachsen-cdu seine national patriotische
partei sich so klar davon zu
distanzieren letztlich und auf einen
klassischen merkel kurs einzuschwenken
hat nochmal die werte für in den letzten
zwei wochen ganz offensichtlich
verbessert er wollte nie mit der fdp
koalieren das hat er gesagt aber die
inhaltliche abgrenzung ist krass
ausgefallen in den letzten zwei wochen
nun kommt man natürlich bei solchen
landtagswahlen gleich zwei an einem tag
immer auch auf die wirkung die
signalwirkung für den bund
was würde denn jetzt gerade dieses
beschriebene sachsen ergebnis auch für
annegret kramp karrenbauer die ja etwas
glücklos agierende cdu bundesvorsitzende
bedeuten wie wichtig ist es für sie
es ist wichtig sie braucht auch mal
rückenwind sie braucht positive
nachrichten
grundsätzlich hat sich berlin ein
bisschen immunisiert gegen das was sich
hier abspielt ist man eindruck und
rechnet mit allem aber grundsätzlich
braucht sie den erfolg dass ein
ministerpräsident in ihrer fallons der
verschiedenen ministerpräsident auch
erhalten bleibt und nicht wegbricht
dankeschön professor korte mal für diese
einordnungen vor 18 uhr
und wir haben jetzt genau noch meine
damen und herren
15 14 sekunden bis zur prognose wappnen
sie sich
wir tun es auch wir beginnen mit der
landtagswahl in sachsen in drei sekunden
die prognose für das land sachsen cdu
bei 33,5 prozent mit verlusten linke
10,5 prozent deutliche verluste spd 8
mit verlusten
afg 27,5 sehr starke gewinne grüne 8 mit
gewinnen fdp 4,5 fast unverändert und er
nicht im landtag freie wähler mit
leichten gewinnen auch nicht im landtag
andere zusammen 5% wir kommen zur
prognose für die landtagswahl
brandenburg spd 26,5 prozent mit
verlusten cdu 15,5 prozent deutliche
verluste linke 10,5 ebenfalls deutliche
verluste
afg 24,5 zweistellige gewinne grüne 10
mit gewinnen
bvb das sind freie wähler in brandenburg
fünf leichte gewinne unglaublich für den
landtag reicht fdp mit 4,5 leichten
gewinnen aber wohl eher nicht im landtag
andere zusammen 3,5 prozent also dass
die prognose ergebnisse was das jetzt
für die sitzverteilung in den landtagen
bedeutet für mögliche koalitionen
matthias vorne und auch david china
beginnen wir wieder in sachsen und
schauen uns an was das für den landtag
hier in dresden heißt an sitzen die
absolute mehrheit bei 61 sitzen
die cdu käme auf 46 sitze die linke auf
die spd auf 11 die afg auf 38 da müssen
wir einen kleinen moment jetzt anhalten
und etwas erklären an dieser stelle denn
das bedeutet sie hat nur 30 kandidaten
genehmigt bekommen für die wahlliste
durchs landesverfassungsgericht das
heißt sie wird absehbarer weise einige
kandidaten haben einige plätze die sie
nicht mit kandidaten besetzen kann
wir schauen weiter auf die möglichen
koalitionen die es hier in sachsen geben
könnte wir sehen den senkrechten strich
hier drüben da muss man drüber bitte
absoluten mehrheit 61
die bisher regierende regierung cdu spd
57 kommt
darauf nicht cdu spd und grüne 68 sitze
das würde locker reichen cdu und grüne
57 ebenfalls nicht dazu muss man noch
sagen es ging natürlich rechnerisch auch
cdu und fdp aber hat die cdu klar
ausgeschlossen
deshalb zeigen wir dass nicht jedes mal
wieder und dann schauen wir nach
brandenburg wie dort die sitzverteilung
im potsdamer landtag aussieht die spd 25
sitze die cdu 15
die linke zehn sitze die afg 23 die
grünen 10 und bvd bvb freie wähler
derzeit bei 5 das ist ganz knapp und
wird vielleicht noch wichtig an diesem
abend wenn es darum geht für welche
koalition ist dann reichen könnte und
wir schauen uns das jetzt mal an
widerstand nach der prognose da wäre
spd und linke die bisherige regierung
kommt nicht auf die absolute mehrheit
von 45 wenn sie die grünen mit ins boot
holen reichte es derzeit ganz knapp mit
45 sitzen
spd cdu und grüne das würde relativ
deutlich reichen mit 50 das sei so waren
die hochrechnungen für brandenburg
zuletzt und wir springen jetzt wieder
nach sachsen und wir können schon erste
reaktionen einholen
der ministerpräsident von sachsen anhalt
ist reiner haseloff wies zugleich
mitglied im bundesvorstand der cdu
und wir können den gleich befragen hören
zu vorschnell bei wulf schmiese nach wie
dieses sächsische cdu ergebnis
aufgenommen worden ist bei der partei
martin ammann hatte hier den eindruck
dass es besser als man sich erhofft
hatte 33,5 prozent und dann war der
bestellte hier
ministerpräsident kurt biedenkopf war
dort wohl platziert vor leuten mit t
shirts für petzschner jubelt gewidmet
und dann gab es doch eine gewisse
enttäuschung natürlich bei dem großen
afd ergebnis aber auch dass die fdp
wahrscheinlich nicht im sächsischen
landtag ist ja ein potenzieller partner
gewesen wäre für die cdu hier in sachsen
also man hat sich darauf vorbereitet
sich zu freuen man hat sich gefreut und
jetzt hat man das ziel erreicht stärkste
kraft zu sein und die ergebnis für die
letzten beiden europawahl und
bundestagswahl wo die sächsische cdu
schwach war abgelöst zu haben wieder
durch ein gutes drei finger ergebnis
vielen dank wohl schmiese das ist als
erster eindruck interessant jetzt
begrüße ich reiner haselhoff in berlin
wie gesagt sachsen anhaltinische
ministerpräsident und dem bundesvorstand
der cdu erhalte lauf viel jubel für 33,5
prozent
freude darüber dass man rang eins
erobert hat sind sie genauso fröhliche
bei dies ereignis
ja ich bin froh darüber denn wir wissen
ja genau von welchen bahnen gekommen
sind
die bundestagswahl und europawahl hat
die fdp fordert hier die uhr gesehen
und dass wir das letztendlich gedreht
haben das ist denke ich mal ein großer
großer erfolg und ist auch michael
kretschmer zu verdanken der sich ganz
klar positioniert hat und den menschen
klar gesagt hat wenn ihr das verhindern
wollte dass die blauen die stärkste
politische kraft werden wird dann müsst
ihr uns wählen und das ist auch
aufgegangen ist auch ein zeichen für die
regierungsbildung jetzt wir sind zwar
jetzt heute noch am wahlabend aber muss
ja auch in die zukunft denken und mit
dieser position kann er weitere
erfolgreiche politik machen und wir
haben es gesehen herr hase läuft das
werden wohl drei partner werden müssen
das ist dann übrigens wie bei ihnen den
sachsen anhalt die cdu vor einer sehr
starken afd das erfordert einen dritten
partner die kenia koalition ist denn das
auch ihre empfehlung an ihren kollegen
kretzschmar jetzt auf jeden fall es gibt
eine staatspolitische verantwortung
jetzt müssen die parteien in der mitte
zusammen rücken und eine regierung
bilden
man braucht auch eine eigene mehrheit
bei dem was noch zu leisten ist und ich
glaube dass die anderen
das auch zeigen werden dass man schnell
in verhandlungen eintritt und ähnlich
wie das bei uns ja auch funktioniert
eine entsprechende regierung bildet er
hatte dort bleiben sie noch einen moment
bei uns ich will aber hinzunehmen die
stimme von lars klingbeil spd
generalsekretär im bund und mit ihm
schauen wir natürlich zunächst nach
brandenburg da haben wir ja ebenfalls
diese situation der bisher regierende
der ministerpräsident der spd-seite
erobert sich rang eins hält rang eins
vor einer aber wirklich starken spd
erklingt bei sie sind in schwierigen
zeiten ist das für sie dennoch ein
gewisser trost am heutigen abend ja ich
will ihnen ganz offen sagen wenn man
jetzt auf die ersten hochrechnung guckt
das sind sehr gemischte gefühle wenn ich
nach sachs und gucke wo martin dulig und
die spd wirklich gekämpft haben tollen
wahlkampf gemacht haben und dann schaue
ich nach brandenburg und hab gut in
erinnerung dass hier vor ein paar wochen
waren wir fast auf platz 4 in den
umfragen und dann haben dietmar woidke
und die spd in brandenburg losgelegt die
waren geschlossen die haben gekämpft sie
haben darüber geredet was die menschen
in diesem land interessiert und die
haben aufgeholt und jetzt sieht es
danach aus dass sie platz eins behalten
und das ist gutes die menschen in
brandenburg gesagt haben wir wollen
nicht dass die rechtsextremen von der
afg vorne liegen sondern wir wollen
unseren ministerpräsidenten behalten
und da freue ich mich natürlich drüber
lassen sie uns mal kurz ganz auf ihre
parteien brandenburg gucken wir können
uns von 3 steht pansky schildern lassen
wie der moment war in dem das ergebnis
der prognose kam ralf
es war um es kurz zu sagen wie
indifferent einerseits war ein schweigen
es war ein leichtes raunen das war so
etwas macht gottes hören als seien wir
mit dem blauen auge davon gekommen
wenn man die bilder gesehen wurde schon
auch applaudiert mann hatte wie gesagt
fast mit schlimmeren gerechnet und wir
sehen hier oder scholz der vizekanzler
steht hier genauso mit klara geywitz
weil die im zusammenhang brachten burg
als team antreten sie wollen ja spd-chef
beziehungsweise chefin werden und sofern
waren sie in der ersten reihe dabei und
man hat ein bisschen mit gefiebert ob es
denn so kommt dass man wenigstens vorne
liegt aber als die afg zahl kamen da
ging noch mal ein raunen durch den saal
und zwar klar das war knapp und das war
aus sicht der spd nur ein bedingt
befriedigendes ergebnis
ja danke schön reif für diese eindrücke
gemischte gefühle das zeigten auch die
gesichter
er klingt war jetzt wird's ja vermutlich
auf rot-rot-grün hinauslaufen
in brandenburg aber das ist dann doch
schon eher so etwas wie eine art
notgemeinschaft gegen die afg oder also
da bitte ich jetzt einfach um geduld wir
haben jetzt gerade frisch die ersten
hochrechnungen wir warten jetzt ab dass
genaue zahlen vorliegen und dann wird
das vor ort entschieden was für mich
wichtig ist es wir lagen vor ein paar
wochen fast auf platz vier
dietmar woidke die spd in brandenburg
angekämpft die waren geschlossen die
haben das thematisiert was die menschen
interessiert klare kante gegen rechts
das sind alles dinge die dazu geführt
haben dass wir jetzt ein ergebnis
bekommen wo die spd in brandenburg klar
vorne liegt und alles weitere wird sich
im laufe des abends zeigen dafür ist es
wirklich noch zu frisch
vielen dank klingbeil nach berlin und
letzte frage noch mal an
der ministerpräsident von sachsen anhalt
in berlin
herr haselhoff was heißt denn dieser
wahlabend aus ihrer sicht auch wenn man
mal einmal auf die bundesebene schaut
auch für die cdu-bundesvorsitzende ak
gilt da auch mit einem blauen auge davon
gekommen
ich will noch nicht von einem blauen
auge sprechen sondern das ist einfach
jetzt auch die zeit zu sagen wir haben
uns sehr sehr stark engagiert auch in
sachsen aber auch in brandenburg und die
große koalition aus cdu und spd hier in
berlin muss jetzt liefern das heißt wir
haben viele viele ansagen und
versprechungen gemacht die menschen
warten jetzt auf die projekte die zum
beispiel in den
kohle region zu realisieren sind und
wenn wir da jetzt nicht weiter arbeiten
und auch stabilität hin bringen dann
wird sich das bei der nächsten wahl
negativ auszahlen
ich kann nur sagen ein klares zeichen
auch zur fortsetzung der großen
koalition hier in berlin
danke schön an beide gesprächspartner
vielen dank und wir schauen jetzt nach
brandenburg zu martin cordes bei der afg
schaut nochmal aufs prognose ergebnis
24,5 das sind zweistellige gewinne
martin und das wurde sicher gefeiert der
jubel ging hier tatsächlich durch diese
hohe decke des historischen walldorf
einen solchen jubeln hätten bisher nur
aus dem fanblock des fußballstadions
sensationsergebnis für die afg mann
hatte mit guten ergebnissen gerechnet
aber das hatte man tatsächlich in dieser
form hier nicht
andreas kern spitzenkandidat stand
während der prognose schon auf der bühne
bis sofort ans mikrofon hat sich feiern
lassen hat das ergebnis der afg gefeiert
und wir können auch schon mal reinhören
in den tod
dass wir gemeinsam zu essen sollte
dieses ergebnis erreicht aber es ist
besser ausgefallen als ich werde so oft
damit 20 plus x-bow ausgegeben ja ich
hätte mir natürlich gewünscht dass das
sahnehäubchen auf stärkste kraft werden
aber eins zeigt dieses ergebnis diese
prognose und dann das ergebnis sicher
ganz deutlich die afd ist gekommen um zu
bleiben
es wird keine politik zone möglich sein
[Applaus]
so andreas kalbitz war das der afg
spitzenkandidat in brandenburg bei mir
ist jetzt der bundesparteivorsitzende
der afg abmelden schönen guten abend
herr leuten angst so ein erfolgreicher
abend ist das für die afg die am
brandenburg gesehen wir haben sachsen
gesehen dort sagen wir auch noch mal 27
eineinhalb prozent hier in sachsen
hier war allerdings das ziel stärkste
kraft zu werden das ist nicht ganz
geglückt denn noch sind sie erst mal
zufrieden mit diesen ergebnissen heute
abend ich bin nicht nur zufrieden ich
bin hochzufrieden
man sieht ja wer hier der wahlsieger ist
wir haben uns für zweieinhalbfache
gegenüber dem landtagswahlergebnis 14 in
sachsen
wir haben uns mehr als verdoppelt wie es
aussieht in brandenburg ich glaube viel
besser kann es nicht laufen und wir sind
hoch zufrieden das ist der lohn hoch
engagierte arbeit und es ist ein stück
weit auch eine zeitenwende ich sehe es
so an die sache aber das hier ist hell
deutschland war gerne gesagt wird dass
es dunkel deutschland dass es hell
deutschland hier haben die menschen
verstanden welche veränderungen es
bedarf in der größeren zahl als hat
bislang im westen der fall ist und ich
bin sehr sehr stolz auf die bürger
sachsens und brandenburgs dass sie uns
dieses vertrauen in dieser großen zahl
schenken und ich darf sagen meine
freunde hier in sachsen und brandenburg
werden das gewiss nicht enttäuscht
nun sind in beiden ländern vertreter des
sogenannten flügels ihrer partei
erfolgreich gewesen
hat sich damit herr wollten heute im
grunde auch die ausrichtung ihrer partei
entschieden doch hin zu einem klarer
radikaleren extremeren zu einer
extremeren haltung und weg von einer
haltung die eigentlich
im bundesvorstand vertreten wir sind wir
sind keine radikale und keine extreme
partei so oft man versucht uns dass
anzudichten
wir haben eine ganz klare programmatik
auf der stehen alle vom flügel bis zu
den anderen gruppierungen die wir in der
partei haben und in diesen in dieser
programmatik können sie lange nach
extremen positionen suchen sie werden
sie nicht finden
das lokal wird die lage nach den teils
würde man sich ein kallwitz steht
genauso wie ich und alle anderen fest
auf unserem programm und da finden sie
nichts extremes so das so nicht so sehr
sie aufsuchen werden das ist erneuten
danke für die ersten reaktion und wir
gehen jetzt zum sächsischen
ministerpräsidenten der sich seinen
wählern seiner partei stellt
[Applaus]
aber jede frage gibt das nicht gekämpft
damit gearbeitet haben wir haben es
geschafft
es ist eine botschaft die von sachsen
und diesem abend ausgehen
eine große mehrheit für menschen die
positiv für diese dann sehen wir was
wollen das freundliche sachsen hat
geworden herzlich danken
[Applaus]
wir haben uns unterstützt und danke
allen menschen in diesem land gemerkt
haben
diesmal geht es wirklich um eine ganz
besondere wahl und wir kämpfen gemeinsam
dafür
wir wissen dass es darauf ankommt wer
wird stärkste kraft
wer hat den regierung auf fragen wer
stellt die landtagspräsidenten
das ist gelungen oder seid wirklich
unter tag für unser land
unsere leistung aus der sächsischen
union an die vielen jungen leuten die
letzten wochen in die gegend gezogen
sind die genauso tiefe augenringe haben
wie ich die kollegen im technischen
kabinetten aus der landtagsfraktionen
herzlichen dank euch allen ist gemeinsam
geschafft ein toller tag
[Applaus]
die größte arbeit noch vor uns steht es
geht darum eine regierung zu bilden die
gut für dieses land ist wir wissen um
die verantwortung wir gehen mit demut an
die arbeit und wir freuen uns darauf
diesen land eine stabile regierung zu
geben
dazu wird es gespräche geben das
verfahren geht es dann als ich von eurem
ort gehen aber das wichtigste ist getan
wir haben eine klare mehrheit für die
dinge die der zukunft liegen dass dieses
land der zukunft zugewandt ist also die
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt stärken
dass wir in arnstadt positiven
deutschland und meine damen und herren
wir haben jetzt fünf jahre zeit auch mit
ihr zu sprechen die wir das
wir empfehlen unseren projekten setzen
miteinander reden nicht übereinander
dinge beim namen nennen und unserem 60
geht wie ihr von kurt biedenkopf
tatsächlich begangen worden ist das ist
unser auftrag gegeben wir ja gemeinsam
schöne nachricht michael stellt sich da
jetzt in die reihe dieser
ministerpräsidenten er ist hier klar
erst der spitzenplatz für die cdu und er
sagt selbst er wird jetzt die aufgabe
haben eine regierung zu schmieden das
wird schwierig genug die grünen werden
dabei sein so jetzt ist die frage wie
wird das in brandenburg weiter gehen
auch da sind die grünen jetzt gefragt
und da gehen wir jetzt mal hin zu casten
bären zu den grünen in potsdam und hören
mal das ergebnis gehört aufgenommen
wurde
der wertinger hier wurde und hier wird
gefeiert diese zehn prozent von steht
gerade das spitzenduo gemacht und ja
wenn im regen und auch die
bundesvorsitzender wer wort sie haben
gesagt wir sind zweistellig ein großer
erfolg auch wenn die macher an gestanden
hat es ist nicht ganz so viel geboren
bin und fragen profitiert nicht die 15
prozent und das tat sie angedeutet liegt
wohl an taktischen fehlern die dann doch
in der fbw in den letzten minuten
bericht stimme gegeben haben um ihm die
afg als stärkste fraktion im künftigen
brandenburger landtag zu verhindern
hier wird gesagt ist ein großer großer
rückenwind für die grüne
klimaschutzpolitik für ein weltoffenes
brandenburg und riesen gegenentwurf zur
afg und ihr habt dieser dämpfer denen
der in den umfragen nicht umgesetzten
stimmen das schritt jetzt einfach mal
weg geklatscht und insofern große feier
stimmung hier in potsdam bei den grünen
vielen dank während in der tat ist ja
brandenburg auch das land von annalena
baerbock aber wir sehen eben auch häufig
schon sind grüne in umfragen auch ein
bisschen höher eingeschätzt worden hat
sie nachher wirklich dann an die
wahlurne bringen konnten an zustimmung
aber wir haben ja auch eine besondere
situation eben einer klaren
polarisierung und einer konzentration
auf die spitze afd gegen die anderen
wehrmacht an der spitze
das rennen und das führt dann natürlich
auch dazu dass andere das kleinere
parteien zurückfallen für die fdp wäre
das auch bereits gesehen die im moment
soll danach sieht es aus in beiden
ländern nicht im landtag wird vertreten
sein so matthias fornoff rast analyse
daher haben wir erste analyse daten zu
sachsen und schauen uns das gleich mal
an es geht um die cdu die ja das
stärkeverhältnis zur afd drehen konnte
verglichen mit europawahl und
bundestagswahl
und da sehen wir bei der bewertung von
spitzenpolitikern dass michael
kretschmer mit plus 2,3 gut bewertet ist
auch die cdu im land mit 1,6 und schauen
wir jetzt mal auf dem bund in sachsen
ist die bundeskanzlerin mit 1,1 und die
cdu bundespartei mit 1,1 deutlich
schwächer bewertet und von der cdu
matthias gehen da ganz schnell rüber zur
spd brandenburg der ministerpräsident
wollte tritt jetzt vor seine partei
bei allen bedanken dass wir es geschafft
haben wiederum zu zeigen dass es in
diesem land vor allen dingen eine partei
gibt der die menschen vertrauen und das
ist nach wie vor die brandenburger spd
das ist das signal des heutigen abends
euch allen noch mal ganz ganz herzlich
nach wir sind geschlossen in diesem
wahlkampf gegangen wir sind mit vielen
inhalten in diesem wahlkampf gegangen
und vor allen dingen sind wir in diesem
wahlkampf immer besser geworden was auch
die mobilisierung betrifft was den
einsatz betrifft vieler muss unterstützt
olaf scholz ist heute mit hier
hier nochmal herzlichen dank für deine
unterstützung ich bin froh dass wir ein
sehr gutes ergebnis haben was mir sorge
macht ist das ergebnis der fdp das doch
wir stehen weiter in diesem land vor
großen herausforderungen auf die
menschen zuzugehen mit den menschen
dieses land voranzubringen das ist mein
ziel auch für die kommenden jahre
wir werden möglichst schnell in die
sondierungsgespräche gehen um eine
regierung zu haben die eines vereint
erfolg für die menschen im land euch
nochmal ganz ganz herzlichen dank
alles alles gute die arbeit beginnt erst
so wir sehen ein sichtlich erleichterten
dietmar woidke ministerpräsident von
brandenburg der das wohl auch wird
bleiben können wenn er dann eben eine
regierung geschmiedet bekommt und wir
gucken uns mal ein paar analysedaten an
zum brandenburger spd r geht absolut wir
gucken mal auf kandidat und partei
wie werden die bewertet da sehen wir auf
der skala von +5 bis -5 dietmar woidke
bei plus 1,6 das waren vor fünf jahren
noch 2,4 es ist also schwächer spd im
land jetzt 1,322 vor fünf jahren auch da
derselbe trend und spd im bund jetzt 0,6
damals 1,8 also mehrere faktoren die die
spd hier tendenziell schwächen gegenüber
den wahlen vor fünf jahren wir haben
noch eine weitere grafik
schauen uns die gerade an die aussage
zur politik zitat wenn die spd in
brandenburg schlecht abschneidet nun
kann man sagen so schlecht war es nicht
aber doch verluste liegt das vor allem
an der spd im bund und dieser aussage
stimmen fast zwei drittel der befragten
hier in brandenburg zu dankeschön
matthias interessante analyse daten
jetzt gehen wir von der spd in
brandenburg die hier gerade gefeiert hat
das haben wir gesehen
zur spd in sachsen und da sie das
ergebnis deutlich schlechter aus acht
prozent in der prognose einstelligkeit
visa mit drücker wurde das aufgenommen
zerknirscht nämlich an natürlich die
enttäuschung hier bei den
sozialdemokraten die ist groß man muss
aber auch sagen die erwartungen die
waren gar nicht allzu hoch dass man
nicht durch die decke schießen würde das
war doch jedem klar und trotzdem hat man
natürlich gehofft und als man die acht
prozent gehört hat ja da hat man die
zahl hier im saal ich würde mal sagen
recht nüchtern zur kenntnis genommen man
hat es geahnt man hat es befürchtet
schon bei der europawahl hat es sich
angedeutet auch da haben die
sozialdemokraten hier in sachsen nur ein
einstelliges ergebnis erreicht jetzt
also auch bei der landtagswahl das ist
der schlechteste wert für die
sozialdemokraten hier im freistaat seit
1990 und jetzt hofft man natürlich dass
man zumindest weiterregieren kann zb in
einer wir haben es gehört cleaner
koalition einer schwarz grün roten
koalition ob das am ende tatsächlich so
kommt das wird man sehen die vorbehalte
gegen ein solches bündnis die sind ja
durchaus groß es bleibt also spannend
und damit erst einmal zurück ins
wahlstudio zu bettina schausten
vielen dank lisa also acht prozent für
die spd 8 prozent in der prognose in
sachsen auch für die grünen in
brandenburg ist es knapp zweistellig
zehn prozent das wunder gesprächen mit
dem bundesvorsitzenden der grünen robert
habeck der mehr aus berlin zugeschaltet
ist schon genannt herr h weg ihre themen
standen hoch klima umwelt sie sind zwar
im osten wackelkandidaten 5% immer an
der
der hin oder her aber jetzt waren die
erwartungen fast höher sind sie
zufrieden mit diesem abend hatten sie
selbst mehr erwartet
so herr harbecke gar nichts nein all
geschossen ich weiß nicht ob sie mich
hören ich will jetzt gar nichts ja ich
kann aber trotzdem antwort noch ohne die
frage gehört zu haben wahrscheinlich
durch das land über kunden daumen hoch
nehmen dann sage ich einfach was mir
einfällt ohne frage wird bei uns nicht
geantwortet herweck so und deshalb haben
wir jetzt erstmal eine hochrechnung die
wahl abendlicht der dummheit so
hochrechnungen die ersten hier bitte
part ihres vaters so die hochrechnung
kommt aus sachsen 18 uhr 24 da sehen wir
die cdu bei 33,1 prozent die linke bei
10 5 die spd bei 8 die afg bei 27,5
prozent die grünen bei 8,3 die fdp knapp
4,5 wäre damit nicht drin und die freien
wähler mit drei prozent auch nicht jetzt
schauen wir mal auf die gewinne und
verluste die es hier gibt in sachsen und
da sehen wir die cdu verliert 6,3
prozentpunkte die linke 8,4 die spd 4,4
die afg gewinnt 17,8 prozentpunkte dazu
die grünen längst nicht so viel wie
vorhergesagt 2,6 und die fdp von einem
sehr schwachen stand kommend gewinnt 0,7
dazu die freien wähler 1,4 was heißt das
jetzt für die sitzverteilung hier in
dresden die absolute mehrheit liegt bei
61 sitzen die cdu kommt auf 46
die linke auf 14 die spd auf 11 die afg
auf 38 ist im studio und die grünen auf
11 was heißt das für die
regierungsoptionen die es hier in
sachsen gibt cdu und spd die bisherige
regierung käme auf 57 sitze die absolute
mehrheit das ist dieser senkrechte
strich hier optisch liegt bei 61 das
reicht also nicht wenn sie sich die
grünen mit ins boot holen würden kämen
sie auf 68 sitze das reicht sagt schwarz
grün klappt genauso wenig und über cdu
und fdp sprechen wir nicht weil es so
klar ausgeschlossen worden ist schauen
wir auf die zahlen für brandenburg man
die wahlbeteiligung schauen wir uns nach
an für nach jetzt in brandenburg und der
hochrechnung die spd 26,8 die cdu 15,5
die linke 10 7
afd auch hier mit klaren gewinnen 24,1
die grünen 10 prozent und die bvb freie
wähler hier bei 5 prozent also knapp an
der fünf-prozent-hürde
die fdb fdp bei 4,5 auch hier noch mal
gewinne und verluste wir haben es gesagt
es gibt kräftige umwälzungen in beiden
ländern
die spd verliert 5 prozentpunkte die cdu
verliert sogar 7
die linke fast 8 die afg gewinnt fast
zwölf prozentpunkte dazu
die grünen 3,8 die freien wähler 2,3 und
die fdp gewinnt 3 prozentpunkte dazu
trotzdem ist nicht klar ob sie im
brandenburger landtag vertreten sein
wird oder nicht wir kommen zur
sitzverteilung absolute mehrheit liegt
bei 45 die spd käme auf 26 cdu 15
die linke zehn die afd 23 die grünen 9
und die freien wähler wenn sie denn drin
während fünf und das ist ganz
entscheidend auch für das was man als
nächstes sehen nämlich die möglichen
regierungskonstellationen absolute
mehrheit bei 45 sitzen spd und linke das
bisherige bündnis verfehlt das deutlich
spd-linke wenn sie die grünen mit dabei
hätten kämen exakt auf diese zahl
haarscharf würde es reichen und spd cdu
mit grünen das würde deutlich erreichen
ein wort noch zur wahlbeteiligung die
liegt in beiden ländern deutlich höher
in sachsen ist sie gestiegen von 49,2
auf 65 prozent und in brandenburg von
47,9 auf 60 prozent
das sind ja wirklich spannende
ergebnisse wenn die polarisierung groß
ist dann steigt auch die wahlbeteiligung
das ist eine alte erkenntnis so wir
haben gesehen im moment
regierungsbildung mit den grünen
besetzen dann noch mal an
schau mal schnell nach sachsen zu tief
fehring und den grünen dort die bei 8
prozent in der prognose liegen
mutters aufgenommen der bediener die
erwartung war natürlich riesig man hat
auch ein gutes zweistelliges ergebnis
gehofft er auch nach der erfolgreichen
europa war noch mal eine ordentliche
schippe draufzulegen dass es nicht
so waren die reaktion zwar freudig aber
doch eher verhalten auch war ein
statement angekündigt worden
von den zwei spitzenkandidaten katja
meier und wohl von günter aber das wurde
da nur so ein nettes dankeschön in die
runde und steht natürlich die künftige
regierung wird in sachsen unmöglich
nicht an den grünen vorbei kommen und
wird also regierungsverantwortung
vermutlich übernehmen müssen
ob das bündnis mit der cdu dann
unterwegs eine liebesbeziehung wird sehr
fraglich sondern wahrscheinlich mit der
von einem zweckbündnis die rede sein
aber noch ist der wahl am natürlich
nicht vorbei und man hofft vielleicht
doch noch ein bisschen zulegen zu können
und damit zurück zu dir bettina
dankeschön die ferien für die eindrücke
dann versuchen wir noch mal ob der ton
jetzt steht zu robert habeck dem
bundesvorsitzenden der grünen herr
habeck ich möchte sie fragen ob sie im
grunde mehr erwartet hatten auch nach
allen form fragen und diesem hoch
stehenden thema klima und umweltschutz
wir haben gerade die verhaltene freude
in sachsen gesehen hatten auch sie mehr
erwartet wenn man es einordnet in den
größeren rahmen ist ein fantastisches
ergebnis das stärkste ergebnis in beiden
bundesländern das wir je hatten und wir
sind ungefähr an dem europawahlergebnis
dran das galt ja als fulminant wir
hatten zwischendurch das stimmt
natürlich eine bessere umfragen auf dem
wahlkampf in den wahlkampf lauf und
denke ich das ist offensichtlich dass
sowohl in brandenburg zur spd wie in
sachsen zur cdu auch grüne wähler
hingegangen sind um zu verhindern dass
die afg stärkste kraft wird
und das ist nachvollziehbar ein
nachvollziehbares wahlverhalten ein
taktisches wahlverhalten dass man dass
ich total okay finde da haben wir aber
sicherlich auch 1 2% nochmal nachgegeben
nun geht es um regierungsbeteiligung für
die grünen also für wackelkandidaten in
die regierung das wird jetzt die frage
sein
ein cdu geführtes kenia bündnis in
sachsen vielleicht rot-rot-grün in
brandenburg über denen sie ihre partei
nicht eigentlich das ist schon eine
große spreizung haben sie die sorge naja
die bündnisse selbst kennen wir ja aus
verschiedenen bundesländern also die
verschiedene die gesamtleitung der
farbpalette ist keine überdehnung für
meine partei
für sachsen muss man allerdings sagen
dass die cdu durchaus ja einen sehr
konservativen kurs gefahren hat und wir
erwarten dass sie sich da ändert
beziehungsweise ihren beitrag leistet
das sachsen eine stabile dann
gestaltende regierung bekommt die cdu
hat außerdem im wahlkampf töne zu den
grünen gesendet die gesagt haben mit
denen gibt's auf keinen fall zur ard
wurde immer auch geblinkt ein bisschen
also ich hoffe dass herr kretschmann
jetzt genug kraft um kreuz hat in seiner
partei dafür zu sorgen dass klar wird
dass keine regierungsbeteiligung und
auch keine tolerierung durch die afg
möglich ist sagte robert habeck der
grünen-bundesvorsitzende dankeschön nach
berlin ja unter klingt schon an dass es
so leicht vermutlich nicht werden wird
jedenfalls nicht mit einer kenia
koalition in sachsen so jetzt schauen
wir mal auf die linke die linken sind in
den prognose und auch in den ersten
hochrechnung werten die verlierer dieser
wahl das muss man sagen und zwar in
sachsen und in brandenburg und wir gehen
jetzt nach sachsen zu den linken stefan
kelch beobachtet dort die wahlparty die
noch nicht so wirklich eine sein kann
damit wird man nicht zufrieden sein
stephan nein es war vorhin sehr sehr
stiller ist die zehn prozent verkündet
wurden
im grunde ist ja das eingetreten was
viele schon befürchtet hatten während
des wahlkampfes
nun hat die linke ihre rolle als
oppositionsführer im sächsischen landtag
verloren abgetreten abgegeben an die afd
die es eben besser verstanden hat sich
als protestpartei zu dem wähler
anzubieten das war eigentlich die rolle
die die linken hier gehabt haben fast 30
jahre lang nun haben sie eine
identitätskrise müssen sich neu erfinden
eine neue rolle definieren
und als hätte er eine vorahnung gehabt
hat schon im wahlkampf der
spitzenkandidat rico gebhardt gesagt
egal wie das jetzt ausgeht
so jetzt hängen in die wunde legt und
jetzt heute hört sich das eher wie ein
notfallprogramm
zurück zu dir ja stefan keller ich werde
einen kleinen aussetzer in der
verbindung aber jetzt sind wir wieder
dabei und können das vertiefen mit der
bundesvorsitzenden der linken katja
kipping schön mit namen frau kipping
eine echte sächsin und dresdnerin lange
ja auch mitglied dieses landtags im
übrigen frau kipping jetzt haben sie
erhebliche verluste wirklich und zwar in
beiden ländern eingefahren warum kommen
in ihre stammwähler abhanden
solche ergebnisse schmerzen echt und
will natürlich gerade weil an so einem
abend auch der zusammenhalt so wichtig
ist all denjenigen danken die unter
wirklich schwierigen bedingungen für uns
wahlkampf gemacht haben und die uns
gewählt haben
zu ihrer frage und das klang ja auch ein
bisschen bei dem bericht an
ich glaub die frage ist ja immer um
welchen protest geht es ich glaube die
linken standen immer für einen protest
der voller achtung gegenüber den
menschen und gegenüber der demokratie
was haben aber gerade im osten glaube
ich viele die erfahrung gemacht dass
diese demokratische protestform
offensichtlich bei den verschiedenen
bundesregierungen keinen eindruck
hinterlassen hat und sehen ob ich haben
sich schon einige jetzt dafür
entschieden auf eine antwort vom zu
setzen das ist also der protest für den
die fdp steht ist ein protest voller
verachtung gegenüber menschen leben und
voller verachtung gegenüber der
demokratie
und insofern ist das eine
besorgniserregende entwicklung sie waren
sozusagen volkspartei in aus deutschland
diese rolle treten sie jetzt quasi ab
wann die afb war man sie da so wenig
rezepte ich habe im wahlkampf immer
wieder folgendes erlebt dass unsere
themen bezahlbares wohnen städten im
stärkung des ländlichen raumes der kampf
gegen den pflegenotstand das waren die
themen die die leute umgetrieben haben
nur bei der wahlentscheidung standen die
inhalte immer an zweiter stelle
also ich hatte den eindruck dass haben
ja auch mehrere gespiegelt auch super
dass sie da sind wir sind inhaltlich
voll bei dieser wahl müsste verstehen da
müssen wir taktisch wählen
und deswegen werden wir eher grün oder
er die cdu und das heißt sie haben auch
noch einmal durch taktische wähler
verloren was müssen sie denn für
konsequenzen ziehen etwa die
die linke in brandenburg rot rot grün
ist hauchdünn im moment könnte nicht
auch eine konsequenz sein zu sagen wir
erholen uns jetzt erstmal womöglich eine
position gut wer 18 uhr bis 18 uhr 35
schon ganz genau weiß an weil allen
ecken das woran das genau gelegen hat
das muss ein sehr kluger mensch sein wir
wären das natürlich auch unter uns sehr
kritisch auswerten so ein erster
eindruck von mir angesichts von
ergebnissen die auch noch ziemlich
schwanken ist der in dieser zugespitzten
polarisierten situation wählen leute
ganz oft nach einer klaren funktion und
die war halt bei uns offensichtlich
nicht so deutlich gegeben sagt die
bundesvorsitzende der linken katja
kipping danke fürs kommen hier ins
studio also die linken wir haben es
gehört die großen verlierer dieses
wahlabends die großen gewinner sind ist
die af dem in sachsen bei 27,5 in der
hochrechnung in brandenburg bei 24,1 und
wir schauen jetzt zur afg hier in
sachsen thomas bärsch shirt und kann uns
noch mal die stimmung schildern thomas
ja nach dem jubel hielt sich die gute
stimmung natürlich wir haben viele
gespräche geführt es war eine gewisse
zufriedenheit zu stören keine euphorie
möglicherweise hat auch der eine oder
andere davon geträumt hier als stärkste
kraft einzulaufen aber man muss
festhalten dass die guten ergebnisse des
letzten jahres hier bestätigt wurden von
der letzten bundestagswahl von den
europawahlen und auch für den umfragen
hier gibt es also offenbar ein stabiles
wählerpotenzial im hinblick auf den
nächsten fünf jahre gibt sich die afg
hier sehr gelassen
man will sich mal anschauen was die
anderen parteien an regierungsarbeit
vorliegen sie hoffen natürlich auf
spannungen und hoffen sich daraus zu
profilieren
gleich nach der 18 uhr prognose gab der
landesvorsitzende jörg urban hier ans
pult und wir haben die bilder und hören
da jetzt rein
liebe freunde liebe freunde heute ist
ein historischer tag
unsere junge partei uns gibt es erst
seit sechs jahren hat die cdu-hochburg
sachsen gehörig ins wanken gebracht wir
haben die höchsten zuwächse
von allen parteien die afd ist heute
abend der wahlsieger ja hat sachsen ins
wanken gebracht das ist richtig 27,5
prozent jetzt gucken wir uns mal ein
paar analysedaten zur stärke der afg
anja und auch zur position im
parteiensystem wir schauen man auf die
bewertung der afg das sind jetzt daten
für sachsen um es vorweg zu sagen für
brandenburg sind sie nicht so anders
wir haben da eine skala von +5 bis -5
bei allen wird die kfd mit minus 1,4
gewertet wenn man jetzt nach
parteianhängern gucken dann sehen wir
ganz viel extrem negative wertungen für
die afg minus 3,4 minus 4,4 bei den
linken anhängern minus 4,5 bei den
grünen und nur ein plus 3,5 bei den
fdp-anhängern selbst und das zeigt eine
polarisierung wir bitten sie mit anderen
parteien normalerweise nicht sehen aber
woher kommen denn die wählerinnen und
wähler der afd
hier in sachsen das schauen wir uns hier
mal an 2014 haben noch cdu gewählt 23
prozent ungefähr in absoluten zahlen
sind das 135000 dann sehen wir von der
linken von der spd afd geblieben 27
prozent andere 14 und nichtwähler 23
prozent also auch noch über 135.000
wähler die die fdk einsammelt wir haben
gefragt und das gilt für beide länder
die heute gewählt haben warum haben sie
denn eigentlich die afg gewählt und da
sehen wir folgendes bild ich wähle die
afd
wegen ihrer politischen forderungen
sagen 70 prozent der wählerinnen und
wähler der haft in sachsen aber nur 43
prozent in brandenburg dort ist es immer
noch mehr eine denkzettelwahl
vielen dank matthias das ist interessant
jetzt haben wir wieder eine
bundespolitische stimme ich begrüße in
berlin den vorsitzenden der
bundestagsfraktion von cdu/csu ralph
brinkhaus schon genannte brinkhaus und
so durchwachsen das bild heute in
brandenburg 15,5 mit deutlichen
verlusten in sachsen allerdings sind die
gut 33 prozent doch offenbar dazu
angetan
ein fröhliches gesicht zu machen der
brinkhaus sie schauen heute abend ganz
auf sachsen oder ja so auch die
kolleginnen und kollegen in brandenburg
haben gekämpft die sind hier aufgerieben
worden zwischen herrn wolke und der afd
das muss man der ehrlichkeit halber auch
sagen in sachsen ist auch ganz
hervorragend gekämpft worden
das ergebnis ist natürlich jetzt nicht
so dass wir in jubel ausbrechen aber der
michael kretschmer hat unglaublich
aufgeholt in den letzten wochen hat
unglaublich gekämpft und das hat sich
gelohnt und da freuen wir uns dann schon
drüber jetzt gucken wir mal auf sachsen
genauer auf kretschmer der ist jetzt nun
mit spd und grünen vermutlich eine kenia
koalition basteln muss die alles andere
als leicht werden dürfte und eine
stärkung ist das doch nicht wirklich
oder
ja aber der michael kretschmer hat auch
in der vergangenheit bewiesen dass er
mit schwierigen situation fertig
geworden ist und die müssen sich jetzt
zusammenraufen und genauso wie er das
heute abend auch schon gesagt hat nach
vorne schauen und sachsen in die zukunft
hinein entwickeln und das werden sie
auch können und dass wir doch michael
kretschmer können 33 prozent gut in
sachsen darüber freuen sie sich aber man
muss es noch mal sagen 27,5 prozent für
die afg in sachsen und da verfestigt
sich ja auch durchaus etwas nicht alle
sagen das ist nur ein denkzettel warum
hat die cdu nicht die wirklichen rezepte
um die afg kleiner zu halten
ja jetzt könnten wir auch nach
westdeutschland gehen dann würden wir
feststellen dass die grünen da relativ
erfolgreich sind und ich denke mal was
wir machen müssen als union ist das was
der michael kretschmer auch gemacht hat
dass unser eigenes ding machen wir
müssen unsere eigene politik machen
nicht nach rechts oder nach links
spielen und das wird auch unsere aufgabe
jetzt seien in der großen koalition
ja was sind die auswirkungen auf die
große koalition stabilisiert dass die
groko heute diese ergebnisse oder eher
nicht
na ja es hat jetzt sich wieder gezeigt
dass wir gut daran tun so wie wir es
auch vor der sommerpause gemacht haben
zu liefern da haben wir die großen
migrations pakete verabschiedet jetzt
erwarten die menschen von uns dass wir
das klima paket verabschieden und dass
wir uns vor allen dingen um das thema
wirtschaft kümmern denn da sind einige
fragen offen
drei springt aus vielen dank der fall
zu uns vorsitzende im deutschen
bundestag von cdu csu
so und nun hören wir mal was die fdp
dazu zu sagen hat in beiden landtagen
verfehlt sie den einzug sowohl in
sachsen wie in den brandenburger landtag
und wir haben dazu den
bundesvorsitzenden christian lindner wir
haben in brandenburg und sachsen
gekämpft auch die bundes partei hat sich
stark engagiert viele abgeordnete
mitglieder der parteiführung waren in
den letzten wochen und monaten viel
unterwegs in brandenburg und in sachsen
unsere beiden landesverbände haben mit
uns gemeinsam tolle kampagnen realisiert
auch dort wo wir strukturell nicht gut
aufgestellt waren
holger zastrow und hans peter goetz
waren hoch engagierte spitzenkandidaten
deshalb bedauern wir sehr
das am heutigen abend nach lage der
dinge die freien demokraten wohl leider
nicht in diese beiden landtage einziehen
wird trotzdem gilt unser dank und
respekt denjenigen die uns unterstützt
haben und natürlich große anerkennung
und dank für unsere wahlkämpfe rinnen
und backen
der fdp-bundesvorsitzende christian
lindner der fdp und ein weiteres
statement von der auch hören nämlich die
spd bundesvorsitzende jedenfalls eine
von derzeit 3 kommissarischen manuela
schwesig dass die polarisierung in der
bevölkerung sich eben in diesen
wahlergebnissen niederschlägt es gibt
viele menschen die in brandenburg und
auch in sachsen ganz klar die
demokratischen parteien gewählt haben um
ein zeichen gegen die afg zu setzen
wir haben aber auch viele menschen die
ganz klar fdp gewählt haben um vor allem
auch protest auszudrücken sagt die spd
bundesvorsitzende wir können später noch
mal ein interview führen
auch mit einem der weiteren
spd-vorsitzenden jetzt wollen wir aber
nochmal auf die stärke der afg schauen
ich sage es noch mal kurz in sachsen
27.5 in der hochrechnung in brandenburg
rund 24% zugeschaltet aus potsdam ist
mir jetzt der partei- und
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp alexander
gauland schön bauland und wir fragen was
bedeuten jetzt diese erfolge des
heutigen abends für ihre partei die ja
eben in beiden ländern erfolgreich war
in sachsen und in brandenburg aber eben
auch erfolge eingefahren hat es extremen
flügels in der kfd des flügels hat sich
damit die künftige ausrichtung ihrer
partei jetzt im grunde entschieden wird
der flügel jetzt stärker den kurs der
partei bestimmen
ich weiß gar nicht wie sie darauf kommen
denn der flügel hat nicht die wahl
gewonnen sondern die guten ergebnisse
sowohl in sachsen wie in brandenburg hat
die afd geworden
das hat mit dem flügel nur soweit zu tun
als andreas kalbitz als ein solcher
exponent gilt das ist aber andere sind
exponenten anderer flügel
von daher hat das gar keine auswirkung
weil wir eine partei sind und nicht
sozusagen unterschiedliche strömungen
und einzeln auftreten nun liest man aber
trotzdem herr kauder ich muss da noch
mal nachhaken in einem internen
strategiepapier das jeder eindruck der
danach aussehe dass die afd eine
rechtsextreme partei sei für die afd
schädlich sei war somit der
spitzenkandidat in brandenburg war
alexandra und andreas kalbitz nach all
den enthüllungen auch über seine
rechtsradikale vergangenheit demnach
schädlich für ihre partei wie soll das
zusammenpassen forsten das passt
wunderbar zusammen denn er ist nicht
rechtsextrem und das was im spiegel als
geschichte steht ist war da nichts oder
sind weiter nichts als behauptungen die
in keiner weise durch irgendetwas
gedeckt sind der spiegel hat seit
renault cius gelernt es wird ja auch nie
gesagt dass er laken kreuz fahne
geschwenkt hat das einzige was letztlich
bleibt ist er ist in einer gruppe mit
gereist
so und da in der gruppe gab es
offensichtlich leute ja die möchte man
sich mit der kneifzange anfassen und das
hat er dann erst gemerkt aber es hat
nichts damit zu tun dass in irgendeiner
weise an irgendwelchen rechtsextreme
ausschreitungen beteiligt war gut
egerland trotz aller wahlerfolge hat man
ja an insgesamt schon den das gefühl der
konflikt um den kurs in ihrer partei
wird heftiger die unruhe größer werden
jetzt diese woche auch erlebt sie
schließen eine landesvorsitzende aus die
dann sich weigert die parteizentrale zu
verlassen haben sie ihre partei als
vorsitzender noch im griff
ich glaube kein parteivorsitzender hat
seine partei im griff das gilt nicht nur
für die afd
das gilt für alle demokratischen
parteien ja demokratische prozesse sind
schwierig ausschlussverfahren sind
schwierig das wissen sie das belegt und
sehen das hat uns clement belegt da die
und so weiter und so weiter das heißt
das sind probleme und ich habe immer
gesagt diese partei ist ein besonders
jähriger auf und diese tätigkeit kommt
dann auch mal wieder zum tragen und das
ist hier wieder zum tragen gekommen und
wir werden klare konsequenzen ziehen
frau sein wird gestalten gehört nicht in
diese partei wir wollen und werden in
den sachsen und in brandenburg sozusagen
die bürgerliche opposition sein denn
wenn sie sich in brandenburg die cdu
angucken dann existiert sie als
bürgerliche oppositionsparteien nicht
mehr und wenn ich die bürgerlichen
kräfte zusammenfasse dann habe ich
überhaupt nichts mit irgendwelchen
rechtsextrem zu tun sagt alexander
gauland der parteien
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp schon nach
potsdam
wir haben hier im studio weitere analyse
daten und widmen uns mal einem
lebensgefühl ost matthias ja absolut
manchmal hilft es ja auch sich so was
mal anzugucken als unterliegende
stimmung die manches erklären kann auch
ein unterschied zwischen wahlverhalten
in ost und west wir schauen die nächste
grafik an da haben wir ein zitat mit dem
wir die befragten konfrontiert haben die
ostdeutschen werden wie bürger zweiter
klasse behandelt da sagen in sachsen 54
prozent ja das stimmt in brandenburg
auch eine knappe mehrheit fand
51 prozent das ist sicher überraschend
in diesem jahr aber es ist ein fakt und
es kann schon sein dass die afd dieses
lebensgefühl als ost kümmererpartei sehr
erfolgreich aufgenommen hat und dass das
die linke die das bisher immer war auch
stimmen gekostet hat dabei ist das soll
vielen dank matthias jetzt schauen wir
mal in denen ins foyer des sächsischen
landtags wo unser kollege michael b
bohrung unterwegs ist und katrin göring
eckardt getroffen hat
so jetzt höre ich gerade er hat sie
getroffen aber das band läuft nicht los
deshalb schauen wir jetzt mal zur fdp am
besten nach potsdam
denn dort waren wir noch nicht fdp hat
wir haben das gerade beim bundes vom
bundesvorsitzenden gehört hat den einzug
so sieht es im moment aus verpasst und
ist an der stelle auch ein stückweit
opfer dieses polarisierten wahlkampfes
geworden wo es dann um die beiden
jeweils an der spitze ging an der
schilling ist in potsdam bei der fdp ja
die enttäuschung wird da ebenso groß
sein wie in sachsen
ja 8 prozent war ja das ziel hier das
war hoch gegriffen denn nicht mal den
einzug ins parlament hat die fdp ihr
wirtschaft dementsprechend bei der
prognose um 18 uhr waren die gesichter
sehr lang die enttäuschung wäre sehr
groß da sieht man mal wieder die
liberalen haben es einfach schwer im
osten die fdp will hier die stimme der
vernunft und freiheit sein wahlkampf hat
sich die fdp als partei verkauft die
eben die rechte des einzelnen stärken
möchte und keine verbots partei sein
will
hans peter goetz der spitzenkandidat der
fdp hat häufig friedrich den großen
zitiert im wahlkampf jeder soll nach
seiner fasson glücklich werden
aber anscheinend hat die fdp damit nicht
punkten können trotzdem hoffen sie hier
weiter und sie zittern um den einzug und
es heißt es wird eine lange nacht
dankeschön einer schilling sohn jetzt
haben wir noch mal die möglichkeit eine
bundes stimme zu hören die spd hatten
war vorhin ganz kurz gehört mit manuela
schwesig zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt
thorsten schäfer gümbel einer der drei
spd kommissarischen spd-vorsitzenden im
moment der schäfer gümbel gucken wir
jetzt mal um zehn vor sieben auf diesen
wahlabend was ist für sie die
hauptbotschaft wahrscheinlich
erleichterung über das ergebnis der spd
in brandenburg maßnahmen mit gemischten
gefühlen so wie ich das eben schon
formuliert habe wir sind natürlich
erleichtert darüber dass dietmar woidke
und die brandenburgische spd wirklich in
dieser aufholjagd über zehn prozent in
den letzten wochen aufgeholt hat wurden
ja an platz drei oder vier vor drei vier
fünf wochen noch gesehen
insofern ist das etwas was uns
erleichtert auch weil es verhindert dass
die kfd stärkste kraft im parlament ist
gleichzeitig sind natürlich die verluste
dennoch schmerzhaft und noch
durchwachsen ist natürlich die situation
in sachsen wo martin dulig wirklich mit
der sächsischen spd einen lebensfrohen
hochgradig engagierten wahlkampf gemacht
hat der unter anderen umständen
sicherlich ein anderes ergebnis gebracht
hätte aber die polarisierung auch dort
zwischen der union und der afg hat das
nicht möglich gemacht und geht da auch
ein stück verantwortung auf ihre kappe
weil natürlich die bundes-spd den
wahlkämpfern in den ländern keinerlei
rückenwind gegeben hat in dem zustand in
dem sie derzeit ist also wie es gibt nur
eine spd und deswegen ist am ende alles
klar dass alle ihre mitverantwortung
haben und dass wir aus der bundesspitze
kein rückenwind geben konnten und
gegeben haben das wissen alle
beteiligten
wir haben den letzten wochen allerdings
auch mit einer sehr geschlossenen
führungssituationen in der bundes-spd in
verbindung auch mit den landesverbänden
mit dem versuch insbesondere auch beim
soli und in der vermögenssteuer ein paar
akzente zu setzen schon auch die
richtung des marktes gehen kann also
geschlossene mannschaftsleistung das ist
glaube ich schon ein stichwort das man
heute benennen muss das in den letzten
tagen und wochen sehr geholfen hat dafür
dass man zu diesen erfolgen gekommen ist
zumindest was brandenburg angeht aber
ich will das in aller klarheit sagen wir
haben viel luft nach oben
beschleunigt dieser wahlabend die
auflösungserscheinungen der kokon also
ich habe das leben ja auch schon einmal
gesagt ich nehme wahr dass viele vor
diesem wahlabend erstens gesagt haben
wir das wahlergebnis sein wird die
müssen das weit überwiegend wieder
einrollen genauso was die prognose
angeht was daraus folgt mein eindruck
ist nach wie vor dass die
koalitionsparteien deutlich konstruktiv
und engagiert miteinander
seit der sommerpause miteinander umgehen
auch in der sommerpause
dass es natürlich auch inhaltliche
unterschiede gibt keine frage
ich fände es oder hätte es klug gefunden
wir zur grundrente vor den wahlen eine
entscheidung gefunden hätten das war
nicht mehr
aber es ist klar dass diese koalition
jetzt weiter arbeiten wir werden eine
halbzeitbilanz machen und dann unsere
schlüsse strategisch wie inhaltlich
daraus ziehen
aber wir haben in den nächsten tagen mit
blick auf die entscheidung des klima
kabinetts nun wirklich alle hände voll
zu tun und darauf konzentrieren wir uns
ich will das wirklich sagen die
verunsicherung die wir teilweise im land
spüren die hat ja auch was damit zu tun
dass die leute zweifeln daran ob der
demokratische staat überhaupt die großen
herausforderung noch lösen kann und
gerade beim thema klima sind wir jetzt
in der verantwortung dazu eine antwort
zu geben und wenn das gelingt dann bin
ich optimistisch dass sich das insgesamt
auch verändern kann
ganz kurz nach schäfer gümbel ich habe
sie richtig verstanden die gruppe soll
weiterarbeiten und dann ganz unabhängig
davon wer jetzt spd bundesvorsitzender
wird der prozess geht ja jetzt los der
prozess geht los wir starten am mittwoch
in saarbrücken
ich kann das immer wieder erwähnen wir
haben unsere mitglieder befragt welche
wich fragen sind ihnen wichtig und es
ist beileibe nicht die coco frage
sondern wichtig ist den mitgliedern nach
dieser umfrage die wir gemacht haben
was ist die rolle der spd in zukunft wie
gehen wir mit den klimathemen um wie
gehen wir mit zunehmender ungleichheit
um also all die fragen die ja auch viele
menschen im land beschäftigen und
deswegen ist ein spannender prozess für
die spd und das ganze land
thorsten schäfer gümbel herzlichen dank
nach berlin so ein abend mit gemischten
gefühlen für die spd im grunde auch für
die cdu die sich natürlich in
brandenburg deutlich mehr vorgenommen
hatte da wollte man eine wende schaffen
15 5 prozent in der hochrechnung das ist
nicht sonderlich gut wir schauen mal
dort hin zur cdu nach potsdam und
christina von ungern sternberg an uns
die stimmung schildern
bettina also hier kann man die frage ob
die cdu in ostdeutschland noch eine
volkspartei ist ganz klar mit ja nein
vielleicht beantworten als die zahlen
kamen das steht fest da konnte man hier
erst großem jubel hören als man die
ergebnisse aus sachsen gehört und
gesehen hat und dann war das entsetzen
groß als man die eigenen zahlen zu
gesicht bekommen hat denn das ist das
schlechteste ergebnis was die cdu in
brandenburg jemals eingefahren hat und
das obwohl der spitzenkandidat ingo
senftleben eigentlich gestartet war hier
um ministerpräsident zu werden was die
location heute abend angeht wollte man
eigentlich woanders feiern da gab es
allerdings ein wasserschaden jetzt ist
die cdu kurzfristig ausgewichen
in den tagungsraum eines hotels hier
mitten in potsdam
man versucht das beste daraus zu machen
wie man insgesamt bei der cdu versucht
das beste aus allem zu machen ja danke
schön christina von ungern sternberg war
das mit einem eindruck der cdu in
brandenburg und jetzt schauen wir auf
die cdu in sachsen bei mir ist nämlich
kurz vor unserer 19 uhr heute sendung
schon michael kretschmer angekommen der
ministerpräsident von sachsen und ich
muss einfach erfahren wie groß ist heute
für sie die erleichterung
ich freue mich sehr diese landtag
besteht aus einer großen mehrheit
positiver kräfte die nach vorn gehen
wollen die etwas positives für das land
wollen und mit denen man bestimmt eine
gute regierung für dieses land
zusammenbekommt sie sehen sich selbst
als ein stück weit gewinner dieses
abends mit 33 gut 33 prozent
ich gehe mit demut mit ihrem über
wahlergebnis um weil vor fünf jahren war
es noch ganz anders allerdings stimmt
vor zwei jahren vor einem jahr vor einem
halben jahr bei der europawahl waren wir
noch weit weg von diesem ergebnis wir
haben viel vertrauen zurückbekommen
durch eine ganz harte konsequente arbeit
dieser koalition dieser regierung und
das freut mich und macht mir mut auch
für die nächsten fünf jahre
und es ist ja dennoch noch ziemlich
knapp gewesen 27 prozent für die afg das
ist ein wirklich starkes ergebnis
ich würde wirklich interessieren hier
kann ich mal was sind denn jetzt ihre
erfahrungen eigentlich gewesen was
würden sie jetzt an bilanz ziehen was
ist ein mittel gegen die hf dns hilft
nur miteinander sprechen und im
austausch zu
zuzuhören und dann anzupacken und ich
bin mir sehr sicher in 20 monaten ist es
nicht gelungen so viele dinge zu klären
wir haben vieles auf den weg gebracht in
fünf jahren werden wir viel mehr
erreichen und damit auch viel mehr
menschen auch für die demokratie und für
unseren weg des miteinanders geistern
ich denke auch wir sind an einem punkt
wo es kippt die leute wir haben sorge
vor diesem populismus vor dieser
spaltung der gesellschaft auch das
schaffen wir jetzt in den fünf jahren
die dinge wieder zusammen zu sehen
gehört zur bilanz auch dass sie
vielleicht früher hätten klare rote
linien ziehen müssen in richtung afd
die haben wir immer gezogen es war so
schwierig weil die meisten journalisten
sie nicht hören oder sehen wollen gut
wir reden gleich weiter sie bleiben
bitte für unsere 19 uhr heute sendung
und wir haben ganz schnell noch mal nach
bei ralf schipanski der olaf scholz im
gespräch
dann ist der vizekanzler urlaub scholz
wie demütig ist die spd geworden dass
sie sich über dieses ergebnis freut wir
freuen uns so wird das ergebnis auch
wenn wir wissen dass wir eine bessere
hätten aber es ist wirklich ein sehr
gutes ergebnis
ich finde das erklärt sich auf basis der
sehr guten arbeit der letzten jahre in
der regierung und natürlich auch durch
den sehr engagierten wahlkampf den sieg
und die brandenburgische spd hier
gemacht haben und es ist übrigens ein
zeichen dass es sich lohnt den rücken
gerade zu machen und zu kämpfen
dann zahlt sich das auch aus empfinden
sie das denn als rückenwind für ihre
bewerbung spd-vorsitzender zu werden ich
glaube weil die dinge sollte man nicht
vermischen das ist gut für die spd dass
es so gewesen ist und übrigens das will
ich bei der gelegenheit auch sagen
martin dulig und die sächsische spd
haben sich auch sehr eingesetzt die
haben wirklich tapfer gekämpft und
die haben auch gute arbeit geleistet
deshalb bin ich froh dass es auch besser
ausgefallen ist als gedacht wenn auch
nicht so wie man es sich wünschen
olaf scholz vielen dank für diese erste
stellungnahme und damit zurück zu
bettina schoss er hat sich dank ralf und
eine minute an der tat minuten vor der
19 uhr haben wir noch mal schnell
gelegenheit meine kurze zwischenbilanz
dieses abends zu ziehen profis ab heute
was ist für sie das auffälligste das
wichtigste regierungsbildung sind
weiterhin wirklich die beiden
koalitionsparteien cdu spd schrumpfen
weiter so sofern keine entwicklung die
sich von west und ost überall
gleichermaßen zeigt aber eben auch eine
sehr sehr starke afd und wir sehen schon
eine gewisse polarisierung auch eine
spaltung der länder nach wie vor sind
die meisten weder darf die im westen
nicht im osten das war bei der
europawahl so bei der bundestagswahl
fast doppelt soviel prozentual sich das
sicherlich anders aus hier im osten ist
sie zum alltag geworden ist sie zum
alltag geworden sehen wir schon
irgendeinen signal in richtung auch
berlin kann man das überhaupt ein
bundespolitisches signal hier ablesen
eins zu eins könnte man sagen
ausgeglichen
ich sehe keine rückwirkung auf berlin
das da morgen in irgendeiner weise
rücktritte zu erfolgen haben also auch
kein kurzfristiger bruch der gruppe in
sicht nach allem was wir heute haben
gehört haben vielen dank professor
konnte nach der 19 uhr sprechen wir uns
noch mal wieder und wir geben jetzt 15
sekunden vor der 19 uhr heute sendung
pünktlich nach mainz und melden uns dann
gleich von hier zurück bis dahin
[Musik]